any society that misses out on fifty
percent of his population in this case
the women of this leconte makers that
for me was a very important takeaway
from the session two other looking
forward points1 importance of
empowerment of women there is no point
of talking about empowerment we actually
have to do it and education is probably
the best way of provided an empowerment
and another one men have to be
sensitized to the value of women and
women too sometimes women are not as
strong allies of other women which they
have to be but most importantly society
as a whole men and women have to realize
the potential of women respect and
nurture and that is the only way a
society India's in particular will make
it I am Rajat nog from the Asian
Development Bank